Bill O'Reilly says he is sad after
losing his top-rated Fox News show amid
a sexual harassment Scandal O'Reilly
spoke yesterday for the first time since
his ouster on his no spin News podcast
the comments came as Fox News was hit
with a new lawsuit former anchor Andrea
Tantaros accuses Executives of high-tech
retaliation after she complained of
sexual harassment she says they hacked
her phone and emails Anna Werner is at
Fox News headquarters right here in New
York Anna good morning
good morning well Bill O'Reilly said he
was shaken by his ouster and if Fox News
thought that getting rid of him last
week would move them Beyond negative
headlines they were wrong yet another
lawsuit makes new claims against
multiple Fox executives
I am sad that I'm not on television
anymore I was very surprised how it all
turned out I can't say a lot because
there's much stuff going on right now
that was Bill O'Reilly last night on his
podcast hi I'm Bill O'Reilly reporting
from Washington nearly a week after he
was fired from Fox News the 67 year old
used it to speak directly to his fans
I'm very confident the truth will come
out and when it does I don't know if
you're going to be surprised but I think
you're going to be shaken as I am
O'Reilly released the recording shortly
before Tucker Carlson took over the 8
P.M time slot what O'Reilly did was not
easy he said a high bar that O'Reilly
had occupied for more than 20 years
meanwhile Fox News is facing yet another
lawsuit it's a headline tonight Andrea
Andrea Tantaros who alleges former Fox
News chairman Roger Ailes sexually
harassed her filed a new claim in
federal court this complaint accuses Fox
News Executives of illegally surveilling
her emails and telephone conversations
and then using that private information
to quote intimidate her she was the
subject of a
very vicious social media campaign
against her tantaros's lawyer Judd
berstein says Fox deployed so-called
sock puppet Twitter accounts against her
those kinds of accounts look like real
people but he alleges were actually
controlled by the network Tantaros
claims one of those accounts tweeted
about her dead brother one day after she
had a conversation about him with her
mother the lawsuit alleges another tweet
referenced a friend who had been stung
by a scorpion it's one of those things
where you say this can't be true and
then the more you look you realize it is
true and it's very scary Fox News
lawyers said in a statement that Network
Executives flatly deny tantaros's claims
they have no knowledge of the anonymous
or pseudonymous tweets described in her
complaint they said
we also got a statement from Roger Ailes
his attorney who called this lawsuit
quote an obvious attempt to get
publicity this suit he said has no merit
Nora all right Anna thank you so much